sunday's statement from buckingham
palace says the queen has tested
positive for covert 19 but she will
continue with light duties as she
remains at windsor castle she has what
are described as mild cold-like symptoms
and the palace says she will follow
isolation guidelines it's not known how
she contracted the virus on wednesday
she met with representatives of the
british armed forces at windsor castle
the previous week her son prince charles
tested positive for covid for the second
time the queen had met with charles just
days before his positive test the 95
year old monarch has had three doses of
a coveted vaccine she had been scaling
back her duties in recent months after a
short hospital stay in october and after
spraining her back in november and often
even people who develop
severe symptoms eventually start off
mild so i think anybody of that any
person of that age
will need to be monitored fairly
carefully the diagnosis adds to what has
been a difficult week for the queen on
tuesday prince andrew settled his civil
lawsuit out of court with virginia du
frey the woman who says he sexually
assaulted her when she was 17 and on
wednesday police in london launched an
investigation into prince charles's
charitable foundation over allegations
it offered a saudi citizen royal honors
and british citizenship it makes for a
tough start to the queen's platinum
jubilee year she will turn 96 in april
redmond shannon global news london